hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the long-awaited
return of among the sleep now I actually
did not know that there was additional
DLC for this game made until just
recently and I'm very very eager to get
it back into it because it's one of my
favorite games of all time you literally
play as a toddler trying to explore the
world and find out what in the world
happened to your mother or your family
and for some reason we're waking up in a
snow field am I looking for Santa Claus
is that what I'm doing on these woods
alone ok sure this is fine oh I forgot
oh the adorable waddle there'll be a
link down in the description below for
the playlist for what I played before in
among the sleep and it is a fantastic
game now this is a prologue I'm not sure
are they moving they're moving aren't
they those are real ok I'm not sure like
I almost
I'm sorry did I just I don't mean do I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay okay it's okay
whatow sees oh never mind them oh I'm
freezing to death in my own crib the
world now this DLC actually came out a
long time ago I just forgot about or I
didn't I didn't forget I just never knew
about it hip can I'm out I still
remember how to pay I'm adorable little
baby so so cool who's saying that I
can't talk I'm a baby oh it's you oh I'm
so sorry I don't know how didn't how to
date how do wait how do I play I've
totally forgotten how to play ah seems
like something that I might have been
able to pick up but maybe not okay so
this game is really interesting because
it all takes place from the perspective
of a child now like I said this is a
prologue to the lat all right cool all
right
anyway what makes this game so
interesting is that it is from the
perspective of a child and being that it
is that everything can seem horrifying
when here at the perspective level of a
child which means that you crawl like a
child you walk like a child you're from
the same height as a child and
everything is a toy but everything is up
to your imagination like what made the
first game really amazing was the fact
that there was so much to see from a new
perspective that had not been seen
before either way I need to oh oh I know
it I need to close the window duh
it should have been my first thing I
need you hey I'm a baby her close it
lock it up good did that fall you up
okay creepy little owl doll that I found
alone in the
woods ole sleepy how about this woman
the man with move thank you monster John
I snappy I don't know if I like you but
okay I'll take you with me creepy owl
person all right where'd you go did you
disappear into my back are you part of
my soul now okay sure alright cool hope
I was going on geez you don't have to
shout it in my ear alright fine then
so as I were as it whoa what the hell is
that
jeez it is terrifying hello what are you
are you snail I don't think I want to
know what you are
oh you're a rat you were much creepier
down below but still I think you might
try to murder me so I'm just gonna be on
my way I'm just a little kid it was my
birthday
where's my mommy hello mommy I don't
think mommy's home right now this kid
has had a messed-up life but what if
what if like the actuality of the
situation was every toddler and you
don't remember it but every toddler goes
through this phase where they actually
like see into the spirit world
oh are you Santa Santa Santa oh oh oh oh
is that a real shadow well I mean it's a
real shadow what I mean
is that a thing that I need to maybe
help who help mama
can I hug you to my chest and make it
warm and glowy
I'm trying oh you're up there oh hey I'm
a-comin oh don't you worry I'm going as
fast as my little baby legs can grew up
remind
okay whose nothing then Oh fine great
okay cool whatever all right then that
was disturbing see the thing about this
game is that a lot of it was so
psychological in that you never knew
what was actually a threat because it
just never seemed like anything really
was because you always remembered like
I'm a child
I will lead your kid I've no idea what I
mean Wow okay those are stumps because
we need firewood because it's cold
wherever we are I don't know why we live
in a Nordic region but I better close
this it'd be irresponsible of me not to
lose it is that a shadow I need to worry
about I don't know what's a good shadow
and what's a bad shadow I'm just gonna
assume that all shadows are bad okay so
I can probably push this chair over
ition way and then I can straighten it
out a little bit like that climb up on
that bad boy over there and then climb
up on it before we go oh look a knife oh
I think I just sliced my finger off who
aren't burning my tootsies okie dokie
horse shut off we all got problems I'm a
little kid that's gonna have severe
psychological issues later in life hurt
her car is that good enough for you your
majesty oh you're welcome mr. Taylor
here please happy hey more happy how
about the blender is that gonna listen
to the soft sultry sounds of this
blender oh I'm a Mike Korean my Japanese
I'm some sort of Asian maybe oh okay oh
okay I know they just need mute no thank
you
ladies this need some sort of a music
what they okay how much like all of this
gonna get the gumdrops you better now
I'm just stepping on all this plastic
cutlery don't believe me
oh yeah you're welcome come with me be
absorbed into my body I shall assume
your life essences are you the fantastic
mr. Fox
well now you're the fantastic part of me
maybe you sniffing me don't sniff the
baby I got that new baby smell if you
know what I mean I like that you know
people smell babies it's not weird I'm
not even gonna just survive how dare you
how dare you get up it how dare you okay
never mind time to move on and find
another creepy woodland creature
oh god it's starting to up stop crying
I'm sorry mama oh sorry hello what did
you over that lorry yeah oh man there's
a Huayra what is that it's in gibberish
for some reason I can't read this Oh
wasn't an Asian language is just because
I'm a toddler and I can't read some the
F
okay I'm not going crazy there was a
noise while I was talking and as soon as
I noticed it it stopped did why
Vicki this house stop crying
how about you stop uh doing whatever it
is you're doing okay what was sniffing
in my ear what was doing that
why was doing that okay oh whoa oh god I
gotta I gotta I gotta hide hide hide
hide hide whew so Joe tells me
somethings about to murder lies me I'm
about to be murdered murdered murder
lies mitr flittered murdered on folder
called
that's that creepy doll I'll get you
more happy just hold on here put on here
hold onto your come on I'm trying it I'm
really I'm trying there no almost had it
not quite apparently
there we go okay now I am it now stop
playing that sassy music and start
playing something nice over to boobity
boobity boo okay I probably need a VCR
to find such that I can pop it in there
and that noise isn't very happy one of
us like this one of us like this at all
there's got to be what's that over there
something over there and I push this
chair nuts too big VCR on the ground duh
yeah Boop press tab to open it boop boop
got it happy happy happy happy happy
thank you so happy look at your beaver
that's a nice beaver I'm will come
getcha I'm gonna absorb your soul I'm
the monster in this place husky okay I
got her good the baby's a real monster
no don't no no no no no no oh all right
so me spitting in my own ear is my own
alarm system for when they're going to
kill me they're basically the longer the
show do this I saw something over there
way something over there I don't want
you here right okay thank you thanks for
that thanks for doing that I'm glad that
happened I'm glad we went through this
ordeal hello hello
he's an office type theater hey perform
forums I have a pipe I'm a dad figure
time hmm stop doing that stop doing that
if there's nothing gonna be there he'd
be if I'm just out of breath okay
someone is leaving town with an airplane
ticket someone was smoking their pay and
someone was on the computron all good
things perfectly normal
this is a thing of that's not stop doing
that I think there's something gonna be
there there's noises here I don't much
like him stop with the noises are really
creepy are we good
okay okay okay all right okay
oh is that Freddy fazbear did my parents
take me to Freddy fazbear's a my future
animatronic just peoples are gonna take
me there and I'm gonna be all mashed
into a suit no this kid does not have a
happy life if that's canon probably not
absolutely no way that's true done yay
okay that's Danna was that a tip that
I'm supposed to go up here it's a tip in
the trick oh what's that
okay there's something up here hello
what is this okay
it's oh oh it's a drawing if mommy and
daddy not being happy well that's
cheerful just like everything else in
this game so happy and fun and free okay
all right so Oh
so anyway I'm gonna finish this up in
another episode I don't know how long
the DLC is but I'm just gonna do
15-minute parts of this so thank you
everybody so much for watching and
remember if you have not seen among the
sleep I cannot recommend it more highly
it's a great series check it out in the
description below thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
just said at leat I tell you very much
everyone
come on what is it
died was it fair